this week on Brian Ross investigates
missing in action with President Trump
seemingly checked out at the cove at 19
response what will that mean for our
country we'll hear from the former
acting the Surgeon General will it cost
lie as you think in the end I think
without a doubt plus a call for help a
rare interview from inside a federal
prison hit with covered 19 whistleblower
revenge what happens when a former spy
and famed whistleblower discovers his
wife is having an affair at her
workplace I called the companies ethics
hotline it's just the way we're wired
and this week's winners and losers in
the media see if you agree with the
choices made by the editors of
beady-eyed Biden once the fuck the
public authority does not from the lawn
crime trial Network this is Brian Ross
investigates good evening and thank you
for joining us and welcome to our
viewers on Facebook live and You Tube
live and I'm joined tonight as always by
my colleague at the law and crime
Network Rhonda Schwartz and Rhonda we
begin with a call for help from inside a
federal prison from a female invit
inmate who is concerned about the spread
of code 19 there Brian coronavirus
sections in prison are on the rise more
than 64 thousand people in state and
federal prisons have tested positive for
kovin a 13% increase this month the
highest rate of infection so far
according to data collected by the
Marshall project in The Associated Press
so it's the infections are on the rise
and as you know Rhonda it's rare to hear
from a prisoner directly inside a
federal prison but one prisoner there a
female by the name of Denise serving
time for mortgage fraud called the law
and crime Network and said she wanted to
speak out even if it meant that she'd be
punished for doing so the women were
forced and I want to make this clear to
the public were forced to go into a male
institution the men's medium Coleman is
the largest
federal prison complex in the United
States there are five prisons there and
approximately 6,500 inmates and there
was a fairly decent outbreak at the met
men's medium facility the women were
forced to go in the warden came to the
female institution and she said your
purpose here is to serve the men's
institution I don't know if she thinks
for a 1950 or what but she then sent all
kinds of women to cook for the man and
do their laundry and now there are 60
with within two weeks of that decision
there are 60 positive Kovac cases at
Coleman camp where there has been none
during this entire pandemic the women
were ordered to go in essentially be the
domestic employees for the male's where
there was a and you the women can't
refuse I take it if the warden says you
have to do it you have to do it you have
a job like a unicorn or some other high
paying or that would be disobeying a
direct order
sanctions for that so do the women have
any recourse at all not really no which
is why so many of them went and now
that's why they're sick you have to be
prepared and most people are not you
have to be prepared to to be penalized
if you choose what they would be
want you to do and how about the fact
that you're speaking here publicly we
last talked we said you you were
essentially punished for talking with me
last time I try to be fair minded and
just big stacks if I speak to the press
being moved and then I got stuck in the
kovat and now I've been stuck in the
Oklahoma Transit Center since I was
moved around what they call diesel
therapy from February 28th to March 13
babe I ever sent to Tallahassee then I
was ten to Lovejoy Georgia to one of the
Geo private prisons and then I was
shipped here why do they call it diesel
it's a form of punishment because I was
treated I was handcuffed shackled at the
wave through a waist chain like I was
like in a maximum-security like area
even though I'm a community custody
camper they made it clear they knew
about those reports both talking so
you've paid a pretty high price in other
words you could be free right now I
don't regret it though but I will
continue to speak out because there
needs to be light shed on the Bureau of
Prisons and how they conduct themselves
or you know and the outrageous
misconduct that they engage in on almost
a daily basis I mean there are some
decent people in it but they are far in
the minority to the people who and
Rhonda we heard from the Bureau of
Prisons late today they denied punishing
anybody for speaking with reporters
that's right they
declined our request for an interview
but they did say that women were female
inmates were required to assist in meal
preparation for male prisoners but did
not come into any contact with male
prisoners and they point everyone to
their website where they described
aggressive measures they put in place
they say early in February with the
guidance of the CDC and that they're
providing limiting visitors and
providing masks to everyone and now
they're increasing testing of
asymptomatic prisoners so they believe
they've had a very aggressive response
to get more insight into all this I
talked earlier with Aaron Haney she's
the policy director at the reform
Alliance a group that seeks prison
reform thank you for being here and as
you just heard from the inmate inside
the federal prison system that Denise
they are deathly afraid of what's
happening a recent report by John
Hopkins and UCLA reported the death rate
was three times as high for inmates as
for the non inmate population it's
absolutely devastating when we look at
what's happening inside of our jails and
our prisons
I remember we talked back in April and
we discussed how fearful folks behind
bars were how fearful their families
were and at that time we were really
hopeful that there was something that
could be done to try to stop this
expedited spread and deadly spread of
the virus behind bars and it has been
just absolutely heartbreaking to see
that in fact it has spread so rapidly
and that it has been so devastating to
people behind bars some nonviolent
offenders near the end of their sentence
have been released is that doing any
good absolutely so the more people that
we can get out from behind bars and the
more that we can do that safely and
swiftly the safer it is for the folks
that are left behind bars the safer it
is for the correctional officers and the
safer it is for the communities at large
we know that what happens behind bars
does not stay behind bars when there is
an outbreak in one of these prisons
very quickly translates to the rest of
the community so ensuring that we are
freeing up as much space as possible so
that people behind bars can foreign team
can social distance as much as possible
and can be as safe as possible is
extremely important so every single
release that occurs is hugely important
in this fight against the virus when we
look at a state for example like
California which is now thinking about
releasing thousands and thousands of
people it is a really brave and
courageous decision that they made to do
that in order to keep in order to keep
the community safe as you know from your
work with the reform Alliance getting
sympathy for inmates for prisoners in
state and federal facilities can often
be difficult have you found that to be a
problem in this case absolutely so I
think especially right now in times when
people are incredibly concerned about
their own families about their own
well-being it's really common for people
to think why should I care about
somebody behind bars somebody who maybe
did something wrong was convicted of
something and so one of the biggest
challenges has been changing the
narrative to remind people the folks
behind bars are people's children
they're people's grandparents they are
human beings none of them were sentenced
to death by virus and it is incredibly
important that we give them that dignity
and that safety that the rest of us are
craving and with many many people who
can be released safely that's exactly
what it means it means allowing them to
go back into the community there's still
accountability they're still monitoring
there's a lot of safeguards in place to
ensure that when they go back they are
going back safely and it frees up space
for those people behind bars who cannot
be safely released who still again have
the right to live and need to be treated
as human beings and need to be safe
Aaron ironically do you think this
pandemic will help highlight the issues
of the incredible incarcerate
rates in this country I think one of the
things that we are seeing with these
releases is that there are a great
number of people who are currently
behind bars who may in fact not need to
be there we've known for some time now
that we have an over incarceration
problem in this country we've known for
some time that over incarceration is
deadly and devastating and this virus
has really really highlighted that so
one of the things that we are seeing is
that when people are moved from behind
bars and back into their community where
they can be safe where they can
contribute we're actually seeing crime
rates drop and we are seeing an overall
positive outcome in the community we're
having correctional officers come
forward and saying you know it's
actually much much better for my job if
the people who don't need to be behind
bars are in fact back in the community
so we are seeing a dramatic overall
positive effect and we are incredibly
hopeful that that is one of the lessons
that we can take from this tragic tragic
situation the notion of throw the book
at them lock them all up but do you
think that is going to slowly fade away
or is there going to be a new push for
that given president Trump's call now
for law and order the law and order
rhetoric and narrative has been along
for so so long has been around for so
long and it's such a powerful powerful
rhetoric for decades politicians have
been afraid of doing anything that could
be seen as soft on crime and it's really
been these decades of making policy
based on exceptions so the most heinous
cases the most unusual cases have led to
many of these policies where we have
thrown the book at people and I think
that what we are seeing right now is
that what really matters are safe
outcomes and so if what gives us the
best chance at safety is in fact letting
people out and into the community then
that is something that we absolutely
have to move toward and so we are
number of courageous politicians I
mentioned earlier you know governor
Gavin Newsom has just announced that he
is going to release over 8,000 people
from California's prison these are all
people who can be released safely these
are all people who would be getting out
soon anyway but it's a very very large
number and we have seen some politicians
leading by example and doing courageous
things to make us all safer finally the
death toll so far inside state and
federal prisons is just above five
hundred inmates who died of covert 19 do
you expect that number to go much higher
or is it going to level off I hope with
all of my heart that it levels off again
these are people's grandmothers and
children's who are behind bars and so we
really really hope that it levels off
but I have to say when we spoke back in
April we were talking at a we were
talking about around 20,000 people who
had tested positive behind bars we are
now very close to 70,000 people we are
looking at prisons like San Quentin in
California where two months ago they had
zero positive cases and now they are
well over 1,000 positive pieces and so
what we have seen is that when states
have been slow to implement you know
reform alliances safer plan and the plan
of many organizations and many advocates
who have called for ensuring that some
of these CDC protections get the folks
behind bars when states have been slow
to do that sadly we have seen death
polls rise and I think that until and
unless we make some very big changes
which do include safe releases we're
going to we're going to continue to see
those numbers climb thank you so much
for joining us again tonight Thank You
Aaron Haney the policy director for the
reform alliance coming up back to school
will it be safe we'll speak with one of
the country's top public health experts
on that very pressing issue you're
watching the law on crime
trial Network more Noah on the kovat 19
pandemic President Trump has now
announced he'll continue or resume his
White House briefings on the issue
although the Washington Post reported
that maybe more about his sagging poll
numbers than anything else the
president's leadership on this issue or
lack of it has been of great concern to
many top public health officials
including dr. Boris lushniak he's the
former commissioner of the Public Health
Service
he was the Acting Surgeon General during
the Obama administration and he's now
Dean of the University of Maryland
School of Public Health dr. lushniak
thank you so much for being with us here
this evening it has become increasingly
clear the President of the United States
has made a decision not to be actively
involved in dealing with this pandemic
from your point of view what are the
implications of that well I think those
are very severe implications you know I
spent 28 years in the federal government
at the CDC at the FDA and within the
office of the US Surgeon General and we
spent many years planning for really bad
public health crises such as this and
one of the key features in all our
planning is the idea that we need to
have leadership we need to have
leadership from the national level to be
able to take control of a crisis like
this and to be able to deal with the
crisis like this and I think the fact
that the president is in essence washing
his hands of this putting out you know
all sorts of claims and then putting the
responsibilities back on the states is
not the right approach it's not
something that we had planned for it's
not something that we had practiced for
in the federal level and it's one of the
things that obviously is causing this
major crisis to get worse and will it
cost lie as you think in the end I think
without a doubt I think you know a
simple fact of you know how far we've
gotten behind on to testing the tracing
the idea of isolating a quarantine
individuals that's part of the puzzle
and right off the bat we back in
February ran into problems yes with the
CDC test but the bounce-back has never
really occurred it is true the president
is right we're testing now more than we
ever have before the problem of course
is now there's a huge gap time between
testing and getting the results
that's not leading towards public health
accomplishments in the midst of this
testing along the same lines the idea of
getting the messaging out there with
masks the idea of preventing this that's
a key feature that needs to be
undertaken over the weekend President
Trump went on Fox News and was asked by
chris wallace about this and he sought
again to minimize the impact let's look
at this and get your reaction to what he
said to chris wallace on fox news many
of those cases are young people that
would heal in a day they have the
sniffles and we put it down as a test
many of them don't forget I guess it's
like 99.7% people are going to get
better and in many cases they're going
to get better very quickly we go out and
we look and then on the news look if you
go back to the news all of your even
your wonderful competitors you'll see
cases are up cases are up many of those
cases shouldn't even be cases cases are
up because we have the best testing in
the world and we have the most testing
no country has ever done what we've done
in terms of testing we are the envy of
the world they call and they say the
most incredible job anybody's done is
our job on testing because we're going
to very shortly we're up to 50 million
tests so doctor this sort of nonsensical
argument that we only have cases because
we're testing and that young people get
it they just have the sniffles address
both of those points if you would please
well first of all without a doubt the
younger you are the less of a problem
this is but it's not a zero problem
right you know we know that mortality
goes up as one's age goes up that's a
given but also the idea that somehow
this is over in a day we do know that
some people are totally asymptomatic but
the key feature here is what the key
feature is that this is leading to
spreading further disease to those who
are vulnerable right so what do we have
right now if this we're all done 99.7%
is harmless then why are intensive care
units filling up right why is the death
rate starting to increase once again why
is the medical care system getting
overburdened and and once again
incapable of surging this is not a
benign disease some individuals it is a
benign course for you as an individual
but in reality in society this has
incredible repercussions but with the
numbers of people who are infected with
the numbers who have to be hospitalized
with the numbers that have to be put
into intensive care situation and yes
now with the numbers that are going to
be dying and what are the trend lines
you see for the next several months for
the remainder of the summer in this
country well you know we do our
comparisons all the time and I used to
say early on that that we were blessed
at the beginning because China was ahead
of us in terms of having this pandemic
spreading through China Europe was ahead
of us and we were sort of third in line
we're the third epicenter right and what
we had thought was gonna happen was okay
we'll see what's done correctly in China
and in Europe we'll see what's done
incorrectly and because we're third in
line for this spread will see the
trending follow the patterns that other
countries are following if we do things
right or will buck the system and do
things differently so that we continue
on a downward trend what happened China
went up went down Europe two to four
weeks ahead of us went up went down we
went up then down and then we leveled
off and now what we're seeing is a spike
of that lovely
so the trending right now is towards
further increases of that spike that's
the concern and don't forget we had
perhaps you know a sense that maybe the
summer will be somewhat different for us
this is a novel virus we've not dealt
with this virus before we weren't sure
how is going to behave but we also knew
that in past pandemics influenza for
example there always had been a lull
over the summertime this Lal never
occurred with coronavirus
and so where do you see us in September
or October well right now we have to
start turning things around from this
this continuation of the first surge you
know people always worry about a second
surge happening we've never left the
first search that's our problem and so
where we were originally bracing for
this idea that we'll have a lull over
summer and we have to brace ourselves
for a second surge in September October
November December as we go into the
winter months now we're still in the
first surge and the second surge will
undoubtedly happen sometime down the
line so we have to brace ourselves for a
few very difficult months ahead of us it
seems the only real answer is the
development of a vaccine from your point
of view how is that progressing well
again a vaccine is part of the puzzle
and we certainly know that you know
right now there's there's a handful of
vaccine candidates globally that are
being looked at for that are being
supported by the US government
financially and the hope is one or more
of these vaccines are going to work you
know the reports that are coming out
right now is maybe we'll have something
by the fall that may be viable as a
vaccine don't forget that we have to
look at two things regarding vaccines
one is does it work the second is it
safe so there needs to be a whole lot of
testing going on in the population prior
to being put out there and then we have
the issue of producing enough of this
vaccine to cover the population so
although we may have candidate vaccines
buy as they're saying now late fall
early winter perhaps early 2021 we're
certainly not going to have enough of
this to cover the whole population but
the vaccine isn't the only thing that's
going to save us right now we have to go
back to public health basics and and the
message they'll continue similarly to
what we had in the past put on the mask
stay away from others wash your hands
those are critical critical components
of stopping the spread of kovat 19 they
seem so simple yet so many people seem
to resent them and fight against them
it's become such a political issue
amazingly amazingly I don't know how
this happened you know and again I blame
leadership on this right leadership
resisted two things right they resisted
on the front this is this real is this
going to be a problem and somehow that
spin of questioning of questioning is
this a real pandemic and how serious is
it really continues now six seven months
after the first case came here in the
United States the second aspect of this
is what is the idea that there is no
sense of giving an example and
leadership right of how this needs to be
prevented mixed messages you have
portions of the administration the
Surgeon General the assistant secretary
for health dr. Fauci at NIH all pushing
a message but then you have the leader
of the country backing off from that
message in consistent messaging leads to
a population that is very confused in
the midst of a public health crisis with
this is salvageable right it salvageable
by getting back on board with consistent
health communication based on good
science and finally let me ask you about
schools from your school the University
of Maryland all the way down to pre-k
should the schools be reopened this fall
what are the implications of all of that
well at the University of Maryland what
are we planning on yeah for starting
date is August August 31st we're trying
to plan for roughly 20% of all our
classes undergraduate classes to be held
in person these are classes where the
in-person experience is critical for
that class to be successful however 80%
are going to be online we're also
planning on having some of our students
return to the dorms again taking into
account the factors of density I can
have students living on top of each
other regarding mass use regarding the
idea of canceling major events we're
gonna have to see how all this goes and
the K to 12 is under certain similar
circumstances I think the next few weeks
in particular are going to be critical
as to all whether all these plans fall
into place or not by putting a lot of
people together whether it's in the
classroom or whether it's at a
university or a dorm setting I'll be
honest with you we are increasing risk
we are increasing risk for the spread of
code with 19 so we have to be very
careful in this
decision-making and the president seems
to be pushing to open schools at any
cost
and again that's he goes against the
grain of every single public health
expert out there of all his advisers
regarding this who knows something about
public health
you know the people pushing for school
reopening czar people who don't
understand the spread of this disease
who don't understand how critical it is
for us to be aggressive about stopping
it spread dr. Boris lushniak thank you
so much for joining us really appreciate
it thank you so much coming up next the
legal tangle involving a former CIA spy
and renowned whistleblower who turned
his skills against his ex-wife during an
ugly divorce proceeding you're watching
the long crime trial Network
July 30th is known by many as national
whistleblower day and today and tonight
we have a story about a renowned
whistleblower and former CIA spy who got
in all sorts of legal hot water when he
turned his attentions to his former wife
during an ugly divorce proceedings his
name is John Kiriakou Ronda that's right
Brian and you will remember we first met
John Kiriakou in 2007 he gave a dramatic
interview to you when at ABC News in
which he was the first CIA officer a
whistleblower to reveal and confirm the
CIA's use of waterboarding as torture to
get confessions from prisoners and while
he didn't get it all right he was the
first to break the silence but Kerry aku
says he became a marked man and several
years later he was charged with
revealing other classified information
and he served nearly 23 months in prison
nine stories about something of much
less consequence and significance but it
does give us an idea of what makes
whistleblowers tick with John Kiriakou
old habits seemed to die hard and he is
now in the middle of another
controversial whistleblower episode this
one much less significant and much more
personal involving his ex-wife and her
company the big defense contractor
Northrop Grumman i intercepted emails
between my van wife and a northrop
grumman executive it showed that an
affair had been taking place for quite
some time well over a year and and it
showed that they were meeting in
different foreign locales in order to to
perpetuate it to continue this affair so
essentially you were going to Northrop
Grumman because you wanted to get your
wife in trouble no frankly the way I saw
it is my wife got herself in trouble to
me this was evidence of waste fraud
abuse or illegality which is actually
the definition of whistleblowing that is
in the whistleblower protection law and
so what I wanted to do was to alert
Northrop Grumman to the fact
that this this waste fraud and abuse was
taking place what happened after you
alerted them what happened what did they
tell you to do well I called the
companies ethics hotline it's an
anonymous ethics hotline and I told them
what I had I described it in great
detail and the ethics officer with whom
I spoke told me that I could either send
everything to her and she would
distribute it to the principal's or I
could send it to the principal's
directly I elected to do both kyriakos
sent a load of information that he had
discovered along with personal emails
from his wife's account and photos she
had sent to her business associate some
of them in which she was very scantily
dressed what I expected was that the
company would do an investigation and
then take care of the problem what they
did though is they turned all the
evidence over to my wife and then they
called the police and the Commonwealth's
attorney's office and filed charges
against me and what charges did they
file well interestingly enough the
charges were revenge porn she was
wearing thong underwear or lingerie or
bikinis and in two of the pictures which
were the most revealing I took a sharpie
and I blacked out the naughty bits so
there was no porn
there was no revenge porn and there was
no criminal intent certainly but you
ended up being charged with a crime I
was charged with a crime and then to
make matters worse after I was charged
with a crime
the Arlington County Virginia Police
Department and an FBI group raided my
house it was 22 officers all together
raided my house with a sledgehammer they
smashed a hole in the wall of my kitchen
they took all of my electronics my
desktop my laptop my telephone my iPad
my ipod everything they even took the
GPS out of my car all under the guise of
searching for more revenge porn
there was no revenge porn there never
was any revenge porn and so in the end
the original charges against me were
dropped and no new charges were filed as
a result of that raid Kuryakin has not
brought a lawsuit against the police his
ex-wife and northrup-grumman which said
it had no comment on what it called a
personal matter
kiriakos lawyer is Bruce Fein Northrop
Grumman really was perfidious here after
all John played by the books you know
he's not reckless he asked for guidance
from their whistleblower hotline how
should I do this you know that pledges
anonymity anonymity as you well know
Brian is one of the earmarks of any
successful and viable whistleblower
program because there's this fear of
retaliation I mean this is a mockery of
a whistleblower program you know it
turns into a program to discourage
whistle blowing because Northrop Grumman
will betray you
it's clear you were unhappy with what
was going on with your wife and your
marriage was falling apart
was it a kind of revenge of
whistleblowing I wouldn't call it
revenge whistleblowing in retrospect
maybe I should have I should have been a
little a little more forgiving I suppose
when I stumbled across this information
but you know all in all now with with
hindsight being 20/20 I still believe
that I did the right thing this of
course doesn't this pales in comparison
to the whistleblowing you did about the
CIA and the US government's campaign of
torture it does this is definitely the
minor leagues compared to that
whistleblowing which was also necessary
but you have it in you just to blow the
whistle looks like I spoke to a
psychologist one time who was writing a
book on whistleblowers and he told me
that one of the things he had discovered
was that whistleblowers have an
unusually well-defined sense of right
and wrong but it's far more well defined
than the population at large and and
whistleblowers actually can't help
themselves they have to report evidence
of wrongdoing of waste fraud abuse or
illegality it's just the way we're wired
all right with John Kiriakou thank you
very much for being here today
thanks so much for having me as we said
Northrop Grumman declined to comment as
did kiriakos former wife Heather and the
Arlington County Police Department
coming up next the winners and losers in
this week's media see if you agree with
the editors of media height about what
they say about chris wallace and donald
trump you're watching the long crime
trial Network and we close out our
program tonight with this week's winners
and losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of Mediate and we're joined by a
damag Lockland editor-in-chief of media
which like the law and crime trial
network is part of the Dan Abrams media
empire aidan thank you for being here
let's begin with one of your big winners
Chris Wallace whose contentious
interview with President Trump over the
weekend is still being talked about many
days later look at this one clip and
we'll talk about it's really because
they wanted to fund the police and Biden
once the fun debate where he does not
look he signed a charter with Bernie
Sanders I will get that one just like I
was right in the mortality rate did you
read the chart of the heat nothing about
the funding oh really it says abolish it
says the fuck let's go alright well you
give me the Charter please all right cuz
you've gotta start studying for this he
says defund the police White House never
sent us evidence the Bernie biden
platform calls for defunding or
abolishing police because there is not
it calls for increased funding for
police departments that meet certain
standards Biden has called for
redirecting some police funding for
related programs like mental health
counseling so Chris Wallace really
challenged the president and was proven
to be right Adan right that was a great
little moment right there from Chris
Wallace's interview which aired on Fox
News Sunday this weekend with the
president it was a really wide-ranging
interview it was the first that Chris
Wallace actually got with the president
since 2018 when he interviewed him I
believe around the midterms
and it was
actually Herald it as one of the better
interviews that any reporter has done
with President Donald Trump and I think
that's mainly because of a moment that
you just saw a light like the one you
just saw right there
which is that Chris Wallace will
challenge the President on a claim that
he's making and actually twice in that
interview Trump asked an aide for
evidence to bolster a claim that Chris
Wallace was challenging him on and the
when Chris Wallace was presented with
the evidence he looked at it and
realized that it didn't hold water the
other example was when President Donald
Trump claimed that the United States had
one of the best coronavirus mortality
rate in the world and Chris Wallace
challenged him on that Trump has made to
provide him evidence of it Chris Wallace
did the fact checking and found out that
the president's claim was wrong
so you know it was a really good
interview not just because Chris Wallace
challenged the president in real time he
also did the work afterwards
in fact checking on the other claims
that the president made so that's the
package that aired on Fox News Sunday
this weekend actually had a you know the
full spread of the claims that the
president was making were challenged and
actually put in appropriate contact and
Natan it also seems to underscore the
shortcomings of other major interviews
done with the president by some very big
name anchors yeah I think when you
compare this interviews with a lot of
the other interviews that President
Donald Trump has done most of which he
has done on Fox News which is Chris
Wallace's Network there's a bit of a
discrepancy in how he's treated Margaret
Sullavan at the Washington Post actually
had a column this week that said that
you know despite Chris Wallace doing a
really really good interview with the
president and calling him out on you
know false claims that he's making that
only really serves to underscore how bad
the rest of the network does the opinion
host she's referring to when they
interview the president and let him
skate on everything that chris wallace
challenged upon exactly and then Fox
News got hit this week with another bit
of bad news a lawsuit by two women who
had worked there claiming widespread
sexual misconduct including against Edie
Henry allegations of rape which she has
denied he has since been fired by Fox
News that's another big headache for
them isn't it yeah you know he was far
on July 1st after a fox business
producer made an allegation of
misconduct Fox News investigated it and
fired
Edie Henry now we have found out what
that allegation was it was they fought
to business a producer who is accused at
Henry of rape it's a pretty serious
allegation and in that lawsuit there's
also a couple of other Fox News hosts
that have been named and accused of
sexual harassment by a frequent guest on
the network by the name of Kathy aru so
we'll see more of that coming out in
court as ed Henry's lawyer says they're
gonna challenge it and look forward to
that moving on to another winner poppy
Harlow at CNN who took on a Trump
campaign aide Mercedes slut let's look
at this and see what you think of this
you know what Joe Biden said we can I
promise we can get really really very
that's just to Joe Biden mercy oh that's
not true Mercedes I really do what Joe
Biden is we should and we should
absolutely know what the president
leading in it is the single most
relevant issue for Americans at this
moment in time and we Oliver Sade's and
for the Mercedes plea I think it does a
disservice we got time so we don't have
to talk over one another I think it does
a disservice to our viewer to do that
let's not fight let's talk about the
facts another contentious interviewing
some real-time fact-checking right right
so that was the beginning of the
interview between Mercedes schlopp who
works on the Trump 2020 campaign and
poppy Harlow CNN anchor it actually was
quite civil from then on out after poppy
basically established that she wanted to
have a real debate as opposed to an
argument and it I found that a really
refreshing interview to watch I actually
watched it live because poppy Harlow
basically questioned Mercedes slap on
the president's coronavirus response why
the administration was trying to
discredit dr. Anthony pouchy its top
infectious disease expert in a series of
other questions and when Mercedes flap
responded by effectively sort of trying
to
spin the viewers and the CNN or CNN
anchor poppy Harlow actually had a
evidence to back up her point and it was
a really well researched and
well-founded debate that followed well
one example is that Mercedes lab
dismissed a Quinnipiac poll that showed
President Donald Trump down 15 points to
Joe Biden saying that those holes are
not to be trusted and that they're all
that they're all sort of fake as the
president has claimed and poppy Harlow
actually had a series of tweets that the
president has put out praising that very
polling company so it would stuff like
that where she had sort of a deep
backbench of evidence that she could
back up her points with and sort of put
mercedes lap in the hot seat and it made
for really compelling and fact-based
interview and let's jump ahead to one
more winner joy reed at MSNBC and her
new seven of seven pm anchor slot she
really got quite the booking for her
first show this week former Vice
President Biden former Secretary of
State Hillary Clinton let's look at what
you had to say to her you me me a black
as your vice presidential running mate I
am NOT committed to naming any but the
people I've named and among them there
are four black women so that decision is
underway right now and and by the way
black women have supported me my entire
career you all act like all of a sudden
there's an epiphany in South Carolina I
have had over a ninety six percent
ninety four percent rating in the state
with the eighth largest black community
in the United States of America Delaware
and so they're the ones as that all
saying goes that brought me to the dance
I have been loyal they have been loyal
to me and so it is important that the my
administration I promise you will look
like America so with bookings like that
she's going to be a force to be reckoned
with and the cable news Wars right for
sure and you know we immediate achill of
joy Reeves namely because of the old
blog post that she had that she claimed
were hacked which was a pretty booby
exclaim we've been pretty harsh on
joy read she had her debut taking over
Chris Matthews slot on MSNBC on Monday
night and had some serious bookings you
said Joe Biden she also had Hillary
Clinton on and it was a pretty
compelling show she earned praise from
LeBron James for for the the show and
also got 2.6 million viewers which is a
huge number for MSNBC so a strong debut
for joy rain they're very strong she's
off to a great start with lots of
comments from all over the media sphere
Aiden McLaughlin thank you so much for
joining us and your insights into this
week's winners and losers in the media
and thanks to all you for joining us and
to the team at law on crime for getting
us on the air and off the air
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]